and then I began to form an idea
suddenly I know exactly what I needed to
do can a supplement or a medication
really boost your brainpower increase
your focus and your creativity make you
more charming
that's what anyone who's interested in
nootropics wants to know and that's what
I'm going to address in this video as
well as which nootropics work best how
to use them etc this will serve as your
guide and introduction to the world of
nootropics
so the first thing you should know is
that technically nootropics is
pronounced Neotropics but I find that
weird to say and I've always said
nootropics so I'm sticking with it you
can also refer to nootropics as smart
drugs which basically explains what it
is they do their supplements or drugs
that designed to make you smarter or
that have these side effects of making
me smarter of course if you've watched
this channel before you'll know that the
terms smarter is really rather arbitrary
it doesn't really describe much in
particular so normally you're focusing
on boosting something like concentration
creativity memory social confidence and
different supplements different drugs
each do these things of different
extents some of them are safe some of
them are dangerous some of them we just
don't know and that's the most important
thing to know if you're going to be
experimenting with this kind of thing so
the first nootropic that you've probably
already heard of that you're most
familiar with is caffeine believe it or
not caffeine does fit the description of
a nootropic this is something that we
all take on a regular basis in order to
be more alert more awake in order to
stay above sleep to boost our memories
our focus our attention and that
basically is what a nootropic is some
people would argue that caffeine is not
technically a nootropic because it
doesn't only have positive effects also
has some negative effects but I would
argue that that's true of pretty much
all nootropics
so seeing as we are familiar with
caffeine let's look at how it works and
that will help us to understand how some
of the other nootropics you might take
work and to do that we're first gonna
have to quickly look at the brain and
just to give a quick overview the brain
is made up of lots of neurons neurons
are brain cells they're connected by
tendrils called axons and dendrites and
essentially you have this big web of
neurons each of which represents
different experience and
encode your memories in here and we all
have a different one which forms over
the duration of our lives through brain
plasticity and it can be called your
connectome neurons fire and that's how
we experience things so if a neuron
fires that represents a part of your
body you might feel as they you've been
pinched in that part of your body if
another neuron fires that stores a
memory then you might see that memory
flash up in your mind's eye so that's
how neurons work when you inspire we
call it's an action potential and this
excites the nearby neuron so when one
fight neuron fires others near it become
more likely to fire but they need a lot
of different input in order to cross an
activation threshold at which point they
fire and the chain continues and this is
why remembering one thing might make you
think of something else or why perform
the beginning of the alphabet makes it
easier to follow through and know the
rest of the alphabet new transmitters
are chemicals produced in the brain and
these modulate the way that your neurons
act it can make them more or less likely
to fire that means that they're
excitatory or inhibitory likewise they
can make you feel happy or sad they can
make your neurons more likely to form
new connections when two neurons fire
together at the same time over and over
they become connected and thus one
firing will almost always lead to the
other firing this is the basis of brain
plasticity so when you drink caffeine
what's really happening is that you're
blocking your adenosine receptors
caffeine as a molecule is very similar
to adenosine and thus it lodges into the
receptors in the neurons that are there
to receive adenosine and denizen is an
inhibitory neurotransmitter that means
that it makes the neurons less likely to
fire it's also a byproduct of the energy
process in cells including brain cells
so over the time throughout the day
adenosine builds up in your brain clogs
up your system suppresses activity
across your connectome and you become
drowsy and tires and starts to struggle
to focus so when you drink caffeine
you're blocking those receptors making
the adenosine less effective and thereby
waking yourself back up and as you wake
up the brain alters also produces other
stimulatory neurotransmitters such as
dopamine adrenaline etc so this is how
caffeine makes us more focused and alert
but it can also have some negative
consequences it can make us jittery
can make us nervous essentially it's
producing many of the same
neurotransmitters and hormones that we
associate with stress there's a bit like
stress in a cup you can think of your
body in your brain as always being in
one of two states fight-or-flight or
rest and digest if you're not restful
then you alert and you're focused and
you're wired
so this brings with it two good things
like focus and attention and memory and
bad things like jitters and difficulty
sleeping this is why one of the most
popular and basic nootropic stacks is to
add l-theanine to caffeine l-theanine is
a xanthine like caffeine and it also
comes from plants and can be found in
green tea naturally l-theanine
stimulates the production of gaba which
is gamma amino butyric acid and it also
reduces the activity of glutamate garber
is an inhibitory neurotransmitter
glutamate is an excitatory
neurotransmitter so when you increase
garber and decrease glutamate you bring
down the activity of the brain and this
is why many people find that when you
combine the two you have a kind of calm
focus you increase your dopamine and
your attention and remove the tiredness
that comes from the adenosine but you
reduce activity in the brain in other
ways so you don't get too jittery and on
edge so many people find this to be very
pleasing combination you can get this
combination naturally from yerba mate
tea and Darwin called that the world's
most perfect stimulant so if you're
interested in trying out nootropics and
you want to boost your mental
performance just a little then that's
one interesting way of doing it that's a
very basic beginners stack you can try
out it's completely natural and the side
effects are minimal if you want to up
things lightly then you might try
something like piracetam or another
racetam piracetam increases the brain's
ability to use a sitar choline this is
another excitatory neurotransmitter and
it's one that has been shown to play
important roles in things like memory
and also many people say it boosts their
creativity their appreciation of music
even their verbal fluency and their
focus during conversations so it's said
to have lots of positive benefits and
lots of people find it's a great way to
feel more alert but it works over time
you don't just take it once like
caffeine you need to take it repeatedly
throughout the days and then
your brain will become better at using
that acetylcholine if you're going to
use piracetam it's always recommended
you also take a source of choline
because choline is a precursor to a
sitar choline it's what the brain uses
to create a sitar : if you don't take
choline on top of the press town you may
get headaches because you run out of a
sitar choline many people find frustum
to be useful personally I didn't find
much of an effect and have been somewhat
put off by reports of people getting
brain fog as a result of using piracetam
to want to go up another epsilon then
you might try modafinil modafinil is a
nootropic that is most often likened to
a real-life NZT or limitless pill this
is apparently used by a lot of
one-percenters by a lot of Silicon
Valley CEOs in order for them to get an
edge on their competition it's also used
by some students but it's technically
illegal in a lot of places unless you
have a prescription it's actually a
medication for narcolepsy that being the
condition where you fall asleep without
warning so it's another one that makes
you more awake and will focus similar to
caffeine but to a higher degree it's
apparently been used by the military and
studies and experiments looking at ways
to increase the focus of their fighter
pilots so it is another level on top of
caffeine the mechanisms of action aren't
fully understood but we know that it has
some influence on erection which is a
neurotransmitter that regulates our
sleep/wake cycle and this makes a lot of
sense when you think that it makes you
less tired and more awake
some people use with Daphna who are
nightshift work but a lot of people like
Dave asked me for instance recommend
that you use it in order to work late
into the night to finish projects and to
wake up feeling fresh the next day my
warning here is that there always is a
kind of price to pay when it comes to
skipping sleep eventually you need to
pay that debt or you'll just become more
and more wire than tired which isn't a
good state to be in but is modafinil
like a real limitless pill well in some
ways yes and in some ways know from my
experience it'll make you more focused
yes it will help you to complete
projects and it can help to stave off
tiredness you can work longer hours wake
up early and be productive which are
things I do need to do but on the other
hand it isn't positive across the board
because it can be negative for your
career
tivity creativity occurs when we're more
relaxed and less focused if you see my
video on functional fixedness then
you'll know this when we relax we can
explore our connectome and we can fire
lots of different neurons at the same
time that's how you creating novel
connections and new patterns when you're
very focused when you've got a lot of
cortisol and adrenaline and dopamine
running through your system then you're
focused on just one area on just one
thing and that makes you less creative
even though you're more focused and this
is my problem really with nootropics any
nootropics that focus purely on boosting
one neurotransmitter I always say you
can't pick and choose neurotransmitters
from one acting on one will always have
effects on the others I find that
modafinil removes my appetite which
might sound a good thing but it also
makes me need the loo a lot and a lot of
other people who use it say the same
thing because if you change your Exxon's
if you change your sleep weights like
sleep-wake cycle you're also changing
your eating cycle and your digestion
cycle and you're altering your stress
levels because all these things tie in
likewise anything that increases
dopamine will also increase cortisol
stress
likewise anything that increases garber
is also going to increase melatonin make
you feel sleepy you can't affect just
one neurotransmitter without affecting
the others and you're essentially
putting your brain into one mental state
instead of being able to adapt and
switch between them at will so whilst it
might be useful when you need that laser
focus for a short amount of time but
definitely lasts about 10 hours by the
way it's not over all gonna improve your
performance will actually make you less
social because it make you more anxious
whereas people might use l-theanine or
something like 5-htp in order to be more
social and more confident because that
helps them relax and to be less aware of
their own neuroticism so if you guys I'm
dipping into the nootropics archive and
trying some out again just to refresh my
memory on what they're like right now
I'm using some modafinil and I'm doing
some coding or rather I'm trying to
learn a new coding concept and actually
I'm finding myself a little bit too
wired to take in the information I just
want to keep writing this is perfect for
my copywriting if I was just writing
something boring then it really helps me
to stay attached to the screen but for
absorbing it from
not proving to be all that helpful on
the other hand when I used the new
product from bulletproof which is newer
master neuro Master or something like
that that includes coffee bean extract
which increases BDNF and brain
plasticity and while I can't say for
sure whether it worked or not you know
there's always the element of placebo I
actually found I absorbed a lot of
coding information a lot more
efficiently and effectively than maybe I
normally would like I say it's hard to
be sure but I'll certainly say that when
it comes to new tricks as horses for
courses and that's one of the problems
with using nootropics because when in
life do you just have to do one thing
you don't this modafinil is gonna last
now 10 hours so good luck to me focusing
on this lesson and taking it all in
I just poured cold water onto my coffee
pretty sure anymore never did that so
yeah there's lots more nootropics that
work like this on specific
neurotransmitters but I feel that that's
not really the way that you boost
overall mental performance I'm also very
aware of tolerance of dependence and of
adaptation where you use any nootropic
for too long or any neurotransmitters
stimulated for too long your brain
adapts so when you drink a lot of
caffeine and you block those adenosine
receptors the brain responds by creating
more adenosine receptors so that when
you're not on caffeine you now feel more
tired because you're more sensitive to
adenosine and whilst there are no known
side effects for modafinil or piracetam
there's nothing to say that couldn't
happen as well or there couldn't be
other long-term effects that we don't
know about because there haven't been a
lot of studies looking at the long-term
implications of using nootropics I'm not
saying don't use them I'm saying being
very careful and I don't actually
recommend this kind of nootropic like I
said could be useful as a laser focus at
all for a rare occasion so you don't
adapt to them and only when you're very
careful with where you source it how you
use it start with very small doses etc I
do think we shouldn't overreact to this
either because if you drink alcohol then
actually you're affecting your brain in
a negative way knowingly and that's fine
we do many things that affect our
negatively knowingly so at least with no
tributes you're trying to be something
positive I'm just saying be very careful
and they're not a panacea they won't
turn you into Bradley Cooper from
limitless so what will turn you into
Bradley Cooper's from limitless well
there are a couple of different
alternative strategies when it comes to
nootropics the first I'd like to touch
on briefly are nootropics of boost brain
plasticity so I've talked in the past
about brain plasticity this is any kind
of a nootropic that increases your
brain's ability to grow and learn
so that means things like lion's mane it
means things like magnesium three and
eight things that boost BDNF
brain-derived neurotropic factor because
they encourage the formation of new
connections between your brain and that
can help me to learn now there is such
thing as negative plasticity meaning
that you learn the wrong things you pick
up bad habits or you learn incorrect
information but on the whole increasing
plasticity is a great way to boost
intelligence and actually in my video
and intelligence I concluded that
ultimately smarts equates to adaptation
plus opportunity so I'm not saying that
these are Opena cheer either but I'm
saying that I'm certainly interested in
using things like magnesium three and
eight or like lion's mane or still tap
or even coffee fruit extract in order to
boost your brain plasticity potentially
that's an interesting Avenue that
deserves more attention but the best way
to boost your brainpower is to focus on
things that increase your energy for
your brain and the nutrition available
for your brain so you don't need
necessarily to consume piracetam
to boost your acetylcholine just eating
more choline will have a similar effect
and also stack on top of that an
acetylcholine esterase inhibitor which
means you're inhibiting the enzyme that
breaks down acetylcholine it can get
quite complicated these stacks get very
elaborate and creative the best way to
boost your mental performance with
supplementation is to consume nutrients
things that we know the brain needs to
thrive and operate at its best so I mean
things like omega-3 fatty acid we know
this is fantastic for the brain
it increases cell membrane permeability
so that signals can be sent more easily
to and from the brain
also quite interesting on nootropics
that increase the energy supply to the
brain which can be categorized as
metabolic cognitive enhancers
so here you have things like MCT oil
which is coconut oil a kind of oil which
provides ketones which the brain can use
as an alternative form of energy to
glucose then you have things like
vinpocetine which increase in blood flow
to specific regions of the brain and
then you have anything that increases
mitochondrial function diluting can do
this so can L carnitine often the kind
of things that bodybuilders or athletes
will use in order to run faster creatine
is one of the best and has been shown in
studies to increase scores on IQ tests
it works by letting the body recycle ATP
by converting adp and a MP back into ATP
- in other words giving the brain
slightly more useable energy so you can
focus just that little bit longer
these are beneficial they're very
healthy and nutritious generally they
don't involve any synthetic materials
and can be sourced naturally from your
foods etc vitamins C B complex vitamins
all of these are used to make
neurotransmitters so the brain has
access to more of them when it needs
them another of my absolute favorites at
the moment is cordyceps and cordyceps is
a kind of mushroom that has been shown
to reduce adrenal fatigue and seems to
be very useful in combating kind of
tiredness and that kind of stress that
comes when you're burned out 21st
century syndrome and that's kind of what
I need because I work long hours of
training long hours and this has been
helping me to go for longer before I
reach burnout cordyceps might also help
you to make more use of ATP which means
it would stack a very well with creatine
and that's something I've been using in
combination I also like vitamin D as
well and I'm interested in the use of
cocoa powder I've talked about that on
this channel before so there's tons of
nutrients out there and lots of
superfoods that have all kinds of
benefits that were only just discovering
or researching and if you do some
reading you can find lots of natural
nutrients that boost brain power in the
smallest of ways and if you just
increase your overall diet to include
more of this stuff then you'll see not
huge transformative alterations to your
brain state but just
you feeling better I'll go into
nutrition for the brain and much more
detail in a future video but suffice to
say I think this is the most effective
way to boost your brainpower without any
negative side effects you also get a
bunch of ready-made stacks and these are
basically combinations of lower-level
nootropics that are known to have some
cognitive benefits all stuff together
into one package and that might include
things like ginkgo biloba which is
another supplement increases blood flow
to the brain it might include something
like bacopa or vinpocetine and
l-theanine and choline these things work
fairly effectively in some cases because
they're well designed or they don't work
so well because they're badly designed
you want to be aware of proprietary
blends that means that they don't tell
you the exact ingredients or the
agreeing exact amounts that normally
means you're not getting very much and
you want to be aware of companies that
stuff a whole bunch of stuff in without
really thinking about it and could cause
an overdose generally it's better and
cheaper to salty ingredients yourself
and create your own stacks and to see
what works for you and then that way you
can test what's working over time find
some kind of way to measure your
performance I look at mic words per
minute my output when I'm writing
because that's what I'm trying to
increase and then increase or decrease
specific ingredients depending on what
you have the most luck with of course on
top of this exercise is the most
important because it increases brain
plasticity increases playing red blood
flow to the brain increases your mood
sleep is super important and stimulating
the brain by learning new things
nootropics is not going to replace other
forms of lifestyle choices to have a
much bigger impact on your brain
function and if you want to get bitten
indeed and the best way to do so is to
get outside spend more time outside
you'll feel so much more energetic
you'll sleep so much better people have
lots of energy they tend to spend a lot
of time outside don't aim to feel like
some kind of superhuman version of
yourself
focus wired switched on charming because
it doesn't work like that there isn't
anything out there that will completely
transform your brain for the better
instead just give your brain the
nutrients that you know it needs to
perform its best it's that simple and of
course if you want to experiment with
the nootropics which I do from time
then keep it to moderate doses and use
them just when you need them to get
specific results in the short term tok
found this video useful and interesting
guys if you did then please leave a like
please share it around comment down
below and let me know what you think
use nootropics the disagree or agree
with anything I've said here in future
if you want to see more like this I'll
look at some specific nutrients and
supplements that highly recommend for
boosting brain power lutein being one of
my favorite and I've got lots more to
cover too so if that sounds good then
stay tuned to subscribe and I'll see you
next time thanks a ton for watching bye
for now
you